e
good
morning we'll call the fiscal committee
2024 and looking at the at the
agenda um tab one is the acceptance of
minutes Senator Al dallesandro moves to
accept is there a second second by and
but before we begin I should welcome
Senator Al here to replace Senator
rosenal
welcome okay a second on the
amendment on on the on the minutes is
Senator bdel any further discussion any
corrections or omissions seeing none all
in favor say I I the minutes are adopted
there is nothing under um old
business tabs 3 through 7 are the
consent calendar there have
been by the house four items removed
six items
24388 and
24389 and under Tab
7 244
24412 is there a motion for the rest of
the consent calendar amend
second motion and a second to to uh
accept the consent calendar is there any
further changes or discussion seeing
none you ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose
no yes that consent calendar is adopted
24388 and that is Department of Health
Services represent Edwards has a
question uh thank you Mr chair and uh
good morning good seeing you again just
just yesterday right um I uh have some
basic questions about this I understand
that this is just receiving uh federal
funds and um but I'm I'm curious what
the headcount is for the state's
management of this program how many
people are involved and if you're able
to tell me uh tell me what kind of uh
job requirements they have in order to
fulfill their duties like are they RNs
or they you know administrators what
what what kind of background do they
need for those positions sure good
morning uh Yin wad I'm the director for
the division of Public Health Services
uh representative Edwards thank you for
your question I don't have the specific
headcount of individuals uh in our
tobacco program uh number of the people
in in that program uh which is focused
on Tobacco asthma and cancer are
actually funded by multiple funding
sources so I'll have to to go back and
get back to you with the exact number of
people specifically dedicated to Tobacco
activities most of them are uh
programmatic staff so they're program
staff uh who may have any number of
backgrounds they may have medical
background they may have a background in
um Public Health uh Masters in public
health or other uh Masters train level
training and then experience uh in the
field uh working in whether nonprofits
or other people uh focused on smoking
cation or other chronic disease
work all right followup uh so so I I I
don't mind you not having the answer to
today because it's a surprise but uh
when you if you would email it to me uh
I would like to know what you think the
actual headcount is that would be
attributable to this program and what
the the job skill requirements are for
for these and then um I think it's been
a decade at least that every time this
program comes up we uh somebody will ask
about metrics how do we know that this
is money well spent what what metrics do
you use to to monitor success of this
program sure um and so I'll thank my
colleague Nathan uh was able to pull up
our our budget for the specific program
so we do have five uh FTE assigned to uh
the tobacco program specifically in this
Au so the the answer to that one is five
in terms of the evaluation of programs
we we use a variety of criteria where we
have the Quit Line um obviously the
number of users and and people incoming
calls and people referred to to quit
services or smoking cation Services
would be one metric uh generally it's
number of people that are accessing the
programs and then those people's uh
referrals into smoking sensation uh and
other programs in terms of outcomes of
those programs we do work where there
are vendors involved we we work with
those vendors to ensure people are
staying in the program duration of
services you know ensuring that they're
getting into a program and then also
staying until the services are having an
effect on their behaviors and helping
them quit
smoking okay so and that same email
could you send me the metrics what what
what the standard is and and how we're
measuring it and what the results are
absolutely thank you thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you send that answer to
Mr Kane he'll let everybody else
absolutely share it any other questions
from committee members on this
item second Senator blazel moves to
approve Senator birell moves to what did
I
say I know 20 years and keep giving you
the wrong okay who second I just
remember you was Regina
uh Senator
Bradley any further discussion on this
item seeing none all in favor say I I
oppose no the item is adopted moving on
to
24389 and this deals with the
refugees Senator Edwards is again
recognized was it you representative
representative
uh thank you thank don't have questions
first of all I want to thank is
this director Hampton is that you
sir awesome yes good morning so thank
you and uh associate commissioner
commissioner Landry for responding to my
questions I've been asking these types
of questions related to the refugee
program for quite some time and as
you're aware I provided you an article
that actually started to list the
different I regulations is the wrong
word but uh authorities under which
different refugees have come in from
different places over the past numbers
of years and you were very good and ask
you specifically about some of them
Haitians in Venezuelans and you g gave a
great response which I really appreciate
what I'd like to request is that this
become part of the DHHS dashboard where
you actually have all of the different
categories under which refugees are
considered to be um legally here lack of
better a word and an indication of which
one it is and what year it was as as in
the document that I provided you you
know what year that permission if you
will was granted um and for how long
it's uh for and under what categories
because you actually Drew out a number
of categories um you mentioned
humanitarian parole you mentioned the O
which is what this is about you talked
about the um the TPS which is what I was
asking about and then by child versus
adult and by by gender um as well so
that we can actually see who is the
number the numbers not the people the
numbers of people that are coming in um
and under what Authority they have come
in is that something that you could um
dashboards thank you uh representative
we have some of that data but not all of
that data so some of those categories so
the program serves refugees humanitarian
paroles
asiles
amarian SIV holders Afghans and Iraqis
and uh those who are under the
conventions of torture and uh couple
other
categories those were initiated by
various acts whether it's the refugee
Act of 1980 the immigration
Naturalization Act I believe regions are
governed by two separate acts as well
there's an act in the fiscal year Act of
2008 I believe that governs the SIV so
it varies humanitarian PE Le not all
categories of humanitarian peoly are
eligible for or benefits and services
and who is eligible actually changes and
some who are eligible will also change
for example uh Afghans are no longer uh
if they were to come over eligible as
humanitarian proles ukrainians have
changed depending on uh what Congress
has passed so uh those things uh may
change uh we do not provide and release
publicly uh data based on uh sex
assigned at Birth
gender and uh release those for privacy
and safety reasons of our clientele we
can provide data
on nationality which we do
and by year as well so we are happy to
provide that to you and we can provide
data for example on humanitarian peoes
versus refugees if you would
like yes um and I'll point out you
mentioned law which is great but some of
these are not under law they're under I
don't I don't know what it's called when
the D when DHHS basically just says
we're going to let in the Venezuelans
now
but you have that distinction as well so
I'm just looking for that that as well
and why can't you include the numbers of
peoples I'm not asking about the people
themselves
obviously this is not data that we have
ever tracked nor that we do release
publicly and we do it typically there is
uh small numbers of folks and we do not
release it publicly for uh both privacy
and safety reasons of clients uh
regarding uh versus in law so when you
mentioned humanitarian paroles that is
governed by the immigration
Naturalization Act so that is not
something that is uh
determined
capriciously that is there is no one who
has a temporary protective status that
is solely given or our benefits and
services to say another way just because
you have TPS you would not be eligible
program follow so from your response in
the the written response I understood
that but does that mean you're not
eligible for any program of the state or
federal
government TPS and work authorization
may make you eligible for Medicaid in
certain specific instances if you were a
pregnant person and a
child however there
are not for o benefits and
services okay hi sorry representative if
I could just chime into I think um just
to add on to what Ruben saying again the
federal government heavily prescribes
who and when they can receive the
services and offered by the refugee
resettlement funds and so we we don't
decide that in this state who and who's
to receive the services the federal
government does and so therefore as
Ruben was saying just one run criteria
does not necessarily correlate with the
ability to receive the funding or
Services by the funding from o at the
federal government and then I just
wanted to add as far as the dashboard
we'll we'll take that back and whatever
information we can publicly share in the
way in which you know works for you and
and the committee we will but there are
we do have restrictions to protect
privacy so there's just some data we
can't share in the way that you may be
asking but we'll take that back and look
at what we can and and bring it back to
you for the record would you identify
yourself oh I'm so sorry and Landry
associate commissioner thank you I
apologize I am upset that privacy takes
place over
safety the public always wants to know
how many of these people have come into
our state and we are unable to give them
that number and all this privacy is
blocking that number that's not right we
have a right to know how many refugees
have been sent into our state by the
federal government that should be known
by you and it should be able to be given
to
us if I may respond representative wer
we can share the numbers of refugees
coming into the state through by origin
of country through the refugee
resettlement program what we can't share
necessarily is by gender or by um by age
in in areas because the numbers may be
so small that that may be identifiable
in certain locations but we absolutely
can share the numbers coming in we could
have a 100 Venezuelan gang members but
we're not allowed to know there were so
many between the ages of 16 and
20 male U Mr that doesn't seem correct
Mr chair maybe this conversation might
be better uh if you and I got together
with HHS and discussed this
offline thank you but we do need more
information the public wants it and
they're not being provided move the item
motion to accept the item
second further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I motion is item is
adopted okay nobody's opposed no one's
seven move to item number 40 4
Department of Health and Human
Services representative Edwards has
recognized for a question um thank you
uh Mr chair and uh thank you good
morning I um I'm taking a look at this
and uh I'm a little uh confused by it in
that it appears that this program has an
exceptionally High overhead to um
Services ratio this this looks to be to
me um about for for
$1.2 of overhead we're going to spend $5
on services and so I'm I think I must be
misunderstanding this and I'd like you
to clarify because it's they an
outrageous ratio if that's true yes
thank you uh for the question I'm
Melissa Hardy I'm the division director
for long-term supports and services um
so right now MF Money Follows the person
or mfp is a demonstration project so
right now we are uh we have two
full-time employees one a a program
director and a data analyst we're adding
we're asking to add three temporary
full-time positions in order to get the
program up and running um where we see
our return is when we have um
individuals who are transitioning out of
Nursing Facility placement and back into
the community because of the cost um of
Nursing Facility placement is
significantly higher than um people
living in the community so we're looking
at um about
$70,000 per person to live in a nursing
facility and about $25,000 per person
when somebody is on CFI or transitioning
to the
community and um good morning Nathan Way
Chief Financial Officer uh and and I I
just want to also add in addition to
that this is not the only account where
the services are budgeted there is an
additional account and I can provide
that information to you so you can have
the full picture because just with this
item you're not able to see that cuz
that other account isn't affected by
this request
and follow up all right thank thank you
for that that that's reassuring uh is
this since this is a demo project
um have you had it accepted into the
agency budget is this is this uh an
established program now within the the
now so
um we budgeted a portion of this program
however um we will need to come forward
with a change request at some point
during the either the governor's house
or Senate phase of the budget process to
add the additional federal funds so that
we don't have to come back through
fiscal uh in state fiscal year 26 so
there will be some additional federal
funds to be added to the original agency
asking
representative thank you thank you for
taking my question um I just want to
confirm that the hsri report when it's
available hopefully next month uh will
be made available to LBA so they can let
us know yes and and a second one I asked
you about the UNH it sounded like it was
supposed to be a report um but you
didn't specifically answer whether that
was going to be provided to the public
to us or if it was something else yes it
can be provided we could we can do that
but it's also an ongoing um
collaboration with them as we get our
operational protocol approved so um we
can share what we currently have um from
UNH but it will be evolving as we um get
approval from CMS for our operational
protocol that'd be great and I assume
there's some progress we made since this
actually originated a couple years ago
not just recently or now thank you Senor
bill
just say to approve that's what I
recognize you
for Senate birdell moves to approve
Senator gray
seconds is there any further discussion
on the item seeing none all in favor say
I
I any oppos motion is
adopted moving on to the regular
calendar on Tab eight didn't we 412 pull
412 yes we did
Oh I thought did I skip over that yes
all right let's go back to FIS
department hello again commissioner nice
to see you again good morning morning DJ
beton Court commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department I'm
joined by Michelle Heaton the head of
Edwards had a question uh thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr commissioner um this
is U this is probably something that you
you would do routinely um but I'm just
verifying it that um project one on this
uh program or this request is to conduct
a study and produce a report on the
current status of access to Women's
Health Services in the state existing
impediments to access and ways to
improve access
and I I want to think that DHHS has been
maintaining such a report and I'm I I
just would like to make sure that we're
leveraging what we know between multiple
departments and not just because we have
Federal money we're going to take a make
a fresh report i' I'd like to get some
Synergy there no absolutely and there'll
be an opportunity for us to collaborate
with health and human services in fact I
think we've already received some
corresponden from them on some ideas
that they have and information that they
would like to share what we're
specifically going to look at are the
topics that you cited as it pertains to
Commercial Insurance because obviously
that is where our Focus as a department
is so it's going to be through that lens
that that work will be
conducted and when you have that report
you'll obviously it'll be available for
DHS for okay all right thank you every
everything done under this grant will in
some way shape or form be public okay I
I I thought it was that I just wanted to
verify thank
you Senator birell moves to approve the
item Senator dallesandro second is there
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I any opposed motion
carries moving on to tab eight on the
regular
calendar
24402 Department of Health and Human
Services any discussion on this
item move to
approve Senator Bradley moves to approve
Senator dandro seconds any further
discussion on
24402 seeing none I'll call for the vote
all in favor say I I any opposed item is
nine
24396 representative Lehman moves to
approve second
Senator Grace seconds is there any
further discussion seeing none all in
10 approve second Senator Bradley moves
to approve Senator birdell seconds is
there any further discussion seeing none
of you ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose any any opposed
seeing none that is
11 item number
24414 move to approve Senator grave
moves to approve Senator Bradley seconds
to adopt the item is there any further
discussion seeing none are you ready for
the question all in favor say I any
and t under tab 13 all the informational
items is there anyone wishing further
information on any of these items uh yes
sir I'd like to uh bring up uh 398 the
DHHS operating
dashboard okay questions on the HHS
dashboard
um I'm I'm looking at um the YDC
statistics uh on the average daily
census uh on table six and uh in the
last couple months or so there's there's
been a request to have kind of a public
review uh uh or public facing review of
the procedures that we're going to use
at the Youth Development Center to
manage the census so that so that when
we get to 12 people are are aware of it
in advance when we go from 12 to 18 we
start to implement some kind of active
procedures to keep it under 18 then when
we go over 18 uh and so so as I'm
looking at these census numbers and
we're in that sort of red range of 16 um
I'm I'm curious what the status is of
uh sharing the procedures that'll be
census thank you for the question so
there was there has been uh meetings uh
with I'll answer that Lori Weaver
commissioner Health Human Services um as
we've been talking about engaging all of
the uh stakeholders that touch every
part of that system if you will and
working to address that so I believe in
the beginning of the month there was a a
gathering looking at all of that part of
the the mo there is to look at the the
processes that we use to keep divert
kids out of the JJ system um and using a
similar model so you have a lot of the
same players in the JJ system also
working to tackle so that's jpos that's
judges that's law enforcement that's
Community that's other departments so
that that work is in progress right now
with the goal of really being able to
make sure that kids get into to the
right level of care and not so much to
keep the census down right I mean
ultimately you get the kids in the right
level of care your census should be
down okay and and then when when do you
think that might be sharable when do you
think you'll have enough of a cooked
result on on what that process and
methodology will look like to to start
to share with maybe some of in the
legislature and some in the advocacy
Community I'm sure I'll I'll check with
commissioner uh associate commissioner
Tilly who's uh leading up that effort I
I would think that they already have
minutes from the work that they've done
but in terms of a product of where
they're at I would think within the next
couple of months I think that's great
that'd be fine two months would be fine
and then I uh if I make switch to table
uh eight which is um I think a good news
table and I'm just curious what you
might attribute it to table eight I
think shows a pretty substantial decline
postco on use of the community Mental
Health
Centers and uh and and so I I'm just
curious if you've looked at that Trend
and if there's any uh analysis that we
might want to know about um related to
decline it would be dangerous for me to
answer that alone without Kia Fox here
so um if we could come back to that or
follow up with you that that that' be
that'd be fine uh and then if I could
I'd like to Mr chair may I go to table
11 yes uh table 11 um is a is also a
nice chart that shows we have no DD
waiting list and as I recall the DD
waiting list whether the thing that
determines whether or not there is a
waiting list is if there are unfunded DD
clients needing services and and so this
I didn't say that very well but I think
hopefully you know what I mean um what
what this waiting list does not measure
though is the number of people in the DD
community that are awaiting services
that are just not available that they
are their their services would be fully
funded so therefore they're not on the
waiting list but because there's nobody
available to provide them the services
they're effectively not getting the care
that we want to see happening so so is
is is there is there another I think
this is like a three-year-old topic
where I've been asking for us to have
what I would consider the true weight
list which is the number of clients that
have funding but for which we have a
service shortfall and therefore no
Services thank you for the question I'm
Melissa Hardy division director for
long-term supports and services so we do
um per your request at HHS oversight
committee we do report out on the data
that we do have as far as people who are
funded but do not receive services and
the reasons why so uh we get that
information from our area agencies as
far as if it's a lack of Staffing a lack
of providers um if an individual didn't
want to start services so um we're still
in the process of since we had a large
system change um Gathering all that data
into one uh report that we could easily
share out but I believe we're on the
agenda for next week at HHS to um report
out on the wait list that is excellent
news thank you welcome and and then I
have one more one more uh uh thank you
so much I I don't know if this would be
your question but um so I I forget the
exact terminology of the of the effort
um that you all have been undergoing on
um getting the the um emergency rooms
cleared of the mental health uh clients
and project zero or something I think
it's called um I'm wondering if um if if
it might be appropriate to include in
the stash board in the future where
we're at with the number of of um people
that are still awaiting services and are
therefore unfortunately staged at in the
eers sure it's called Mission zero just
for the record Mission zero thank you
Mission zero um we did include it so
that Dash board has been up for quite a
while if you look at your uh cover page
there is a link to that dashboard
because it's updated daily with counts
so if you look in that first parag uh
second paragraph if you will there's a
link that'll take you where you'll be
able to see uh different facets of the
data and how we break down those that
are waiting that are actually in EDS or
those that are um already uh have a
placement that but are like such as uh
the jail so so I actually knew that I
was just giv you an opportunity need to
brag okay how how well you guys are
sure representative lean I have
something that's not on the
miscellaneous but I think this will
probably be the last meeting that we
have as a group of fiscal uh and there
are two people on the Senate side that I
know that won't be coming back uh Jeb
Bradley who I met back in the 90s when
he was uh
serving as the chair of Science and
Technology in the house also the Ethics
Committee um I have worked with Senator
Bradley on like the New Hampshire Health
protection plan um then I look at Lou
alesandro that used to be a republican
like I was and uh these two individuals
have been lions in the state and I can't
think of two individuals that have done
more positive things for the State of
New Hampshire and I know all of us are
Jeff thank
[Applause]
you thank you for your service so
everybody listen to uh New Hampshire
Public Radio at some point because
Senator D and I are going to do a uh Old
Goat retiring interview this morning
but thank you all very much what's the
do you know the
date we're going to record it at 12:30
so you want to come into the third floor
office everybody can watch us uh get
grilled if first of all thank you Peter
thank you very much and uh it's been an
honor to serve with you and to work with
you over the years I I I must say that
that it's been an honor to work with
Senator Bradley and to work with members
of the committee uh and to hear uh the
quality of service that's presented by
our commissioners and other individuals
who come before us and to bring us
information about how the government
works and how efficient it is or or what
I what our
just what our inability is sometimes to
do the kinds of things that the
legislature wants you to do but
generally
speaking uh we should be very pleased at
at at what's what's happened that uh I I
want to just make one point and that's
the the uh the the commissioner of of
Revenue and and the job that that she
has done with that department to bring
in the the uh the rim system I think is
Magnificent the fact that she's
collecting money that was not collected
in the in the past that money is being
used to pay off a b debt that we don't
have to appropriate General funds for
they'll be paid for by the that's being
ACR and it's things like that that make
government work and we're we're so proud
of in in terms of our ability to to
manage that but we have we have a lot of
problems and uh you know life is a
series of problem solving exercises
that's what life all about and um I've
been here a long time Jeb's been here a
long time and as we leave I I think the
uh the situation is uh we hope things
move in the right direction right that's
what we all we all hope for
because a lot of people are depending on
all of the actions that take place in
this legislative body and U the lives of
people of the State of New Hampshire are
what we're really concerned about that's
why we come here that's why we serve
here and hopefully when we when we leave
it's better than it was when we came
thank you br so uh Senator D always
makes at a great American day and uh
it's really been a pleasure to serve
with Lou and I just want to
um I was kind of joking about our old
goat interview which everybody can come
and and watch us um I think it's a 12:30
right Lou in the third floor office but
um both of us have worked with everybody
in this room for years Peter thank you
very much for your kind words um done a
lot of good bipartison work some par
ofon work um I remember Doug Hall
telling me uh many years ago
the most important trait of any
legislator is when you disagree to
always try to be agreeable and uh I
think Lou you have uh epitomized that
and um it's been a pleasure to work with
you I also want to give Mike you a shout
um I had never sat on the finance
committee until um this budget and
um I just came to realize not only Mike
but the entire LBA staff just does an
exceptional job um and I think has made
the budget process much more transparent
explainable um and was really helpful
and so I think that's uh vitally
important and you also did a great job
of training Nathan um who's done a great
job with all of the HHS people that are
here in the room today you're the
largest Department in uh this great
state and so many people depend on you
and you manage the resources that you're
given I think pretty eff effectively and
efficiently um and that enables us
to um provide services but do it at a in
a rational basis and maintain our
advantageous tax structure which is
really important right L right if I
could Mr chair but the the LBA the the
LBA is just unbelievably unbelievably
good and uh the young woman who answers
the telephone when I call the NBA is is
is the best the best and she's promising
me that she's not going to retire she's
going to hang in and keep pitching now I
remember the LBA when Henry good ran the
LBA now that goes back over 50 years ago
that was my first trip to the office of
the LBA when Henry good had the dark
lights on was smoking in the office
smoking his pipe or his cigar and this
whole world was in a different different
shape at that that time but I can't
thank the LBA enough Mike and and his
crew and uh for for the job that they do
work in the budget uh it's it's just
amazing how six guys can work for the
Senate work for the house work for the
majority work for the minority and and
get it done in a in a know partisan
fashion so Kudos kudos to the LBA and to
uh just as I say to that that young
woman who answers the phone that that
that's the greatest that's the greatest
message you could get good morning good
morning this is the LBA how can I help
you thank you very much thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank
you anything
further this uh will be the last meeting
of this uh fiscal committee it will be
reformed in the next in the next session
and uh I enjoyed working with all of you
and appreciate all the study you have to
do with all these items that come before
us every week or every month rather and
uh it'll be a new challenge in the
future so but if I might I think for all
of us as members Mr chair you and
Senator gray deserve a shout out for you
know really organizing fiscal well never
sat on fiscal before either probably the
most powerful most underknown Committee
of the legislature but both you and Jim
have done a exceptional job over these
um in the future okay printing of these
books cost a lot of money takes a lot of
effort I want to with the departure of
of a couple of our
members that that like the
paper I want I want the new members and
the existing
members excuse me that are returning uh
to think about the way we did it during
co uh that the link that you get with
the agenda uh is very quick very easy to
get back to the
information uh even if someone has to
appropriate the money to get you all a
Chromebook or whatever it is that we
would need to do that um we can we can
actually save some money save some time
um as long as you get a hard copy of
that agenda to keep your notes on I
think that is doable so give us some
thought and uh you know the lb will be
happy not to have to put these all
together if uh if we get there already
there we just get trained by
Keith even has a little thing he can
write on his Chromebook there anything
further thank you all it's delighted to